to take it
one layer deeper on this and the reason
i like this book so much
again the case against reality so he's
making the case that space and time are
not fundamental
yes which i i started my intellectual
explorations in physics actually
astrophysics so for the longest time
even the way i describe money as i talk
about space and time
so that blew my mind but this dovetailed
nicely with another book
called leela the the author is robert
persig so he wrote zen in the art of
motorcycle maintenance which is a very
popular book
20 years later he wrote leela which no
one's heard of which is crazy
and he basically says he was wrong about
his first book and he lays out this
entire other
metaphysics of of quality he calls it so
it's the metaphysics i think it's
metaphysics of quality
but his supposition is that
it's not physical reality that's
fundamental it's not
informational information that's
fundamental it's
value so he actually and it's a
beautiful book i highly recommend it
he essentially is refuting causality
itself
we think a causes b
this book makes the case that
b values precondition a
so that we are actually creating our
future
through our value systems and this goes
back to
um something i think solzhenitsyn said
this that the the line between good and
evil runs down the heart of every man
so it's as if our moral decisions are
actually what's creating
the outcomes in reality over time and
then that gets into all the wisdom
traditions
related to religion or it's always
talking about you know
loving thy neighbor and loving god and
all of these other things that are good
morally
to create the best outcomes so values
are fundamental
value yes value yeah is fundamental
oh boy yeah that's interesting
i mean it does feel like physics is not
capturing
something you know there's some people
uh
pan psychists argue that consciousness
might be one of the fundamental
properties of nature like from which
emerges everything we see so
that could be just other words
for this same notion of value and then
the the basic laws of physics are not
capturing that currently yeah
so maybe humans in order to understand
from where humans came from we have to
understand
these other properties of nature which
are yet to be discovered
right at the physics level and it's
we contend with that underlying nature
whatever it is with
the logos right so we are we're
looking at uncategorized nature
and then we're assigning a word to it so
we're
slicing up chaos into little boxes of
order
and then we're establishing this social
consensus as to those labels
which we'd call words and we're using
that to communicate
and when we communicate um
we can start to build these other things
this is like uh the uval harare
imagined orders so we can create these
useful fictions
right whether it's the nation state or
human rights or money
and that allows us to cooperate flexibly
in large numbers
so that we can better contend with
reality we can produce more complicated
things
we can we can enlarge that bubble of
civilization against
entropy and that's what capitalism is
all about
it's about further specializing
knowledge further enriching
mankind's treasury of knowledge
and doing it but but to do that the
the communication media that we're using
the words have to have stable meaning
the money needs to have value that's
dependable
right it needs to be something that's
it's not dictated by any one group it's
reached by consensus of the entire group
that's how so you think
it's like optimizing for error
correction again
where a free market would be harnessing
the intelligence of all market actors
and a central planning or essentially
planned market would be harnessing just
the intelligence of a small
group of bureaucrats and it's not
obvious how to achieve this kind of
consensus mechanism
i mean there's obviously we'll talk
about sort of bitcoin as an idea
ultimately the idea of bitcoin is
connecting it to
physics so like you can trust that
physical matter won't change
[Music]
but you know there could be other ideas
that were yet maybe physics could be
changed varric einstein has anything to
say about it
like it's it's on you know we right now
believe that physics can't be changed
the physical matter of the world but
maybe you can in a way that we're
totally not understanding you mentioned
sort of reality from um
from donald hoffman's perspective like
if we don't have
even close to direct access to the
fabric of reality
maybe we're living in a world that's
very like many dimensions
that the notions of space and time is
just like a silly useful
construct that's not at all connected
you're starting to
look at like stephen wolfram's i don't
know if you're familiar with this
view of the world that it's like
hypographs underneath it all
like these mathematical structures from
which everything emerges
like they're like uh
like many many many orders of magnitude
smaller than what we think of as they're
even smaller than like strings and
string theory
so like those are the basic mathematical
objects from which it emerges
i don't you know i think that's an
interesting philosophical
framework it's also people should check
out uh
a cool uh way to play with beautiful
hypograph mathematical structures
so he has i don't know if you know
stephen will from his best he
created well from alpha and all these
tools you can actually visualize and
play with
so you can play with physics in a visual
way which
uh uh or at least discreet mathematics
which i think is incredible he doesn't
get enough love
one of the reasons he i think doesn't
get enough love
is because of this little quirk of human
nature which is
the ego and he uh he sometimes
frustrates a few folks because um
he's very let's say proud of his work
you